[Music]
from F1 to Super Bowl there's a lot on
the horizon for Las Vegas but there's
also concern for those driving in from
California for those events that's
getting here is not going to be easy
because there's so much traffic it takes
a while and they blame the prolonged
widening of I-15 for the issues Ryan
Matthey shows us where the project
stands now
it was a project scheduled for
completion nearly a year ago work on the
Nevada side seemingly complete but it's
the California side still needing that
work Clark County officials saying the
state needs to kick it into high gear
makes travel way longer than it needs to
be and it's very uncomfortable Ryan
black had a wild ride into town Friday
in a bottleneck where it goes from two
lanes to one it everybody slammed on
their brakes it came to like a complete
stop all three cars almost got in an
accident
the headache of millions making this 113
mile Trek a year between Barstow and
State Line it should be done by
summertime that's former Nevada Governor
Steve sisilak and current California
governor Gavin Newsom announcing the
widening project in December 2021 but
over a year later miles of backup like
this 18-mile one on New Year's Day so
far the only work done converting the
interstate shoulder at state line into a
third lane for one mile there needs to
be done more in terms of coordination
with the state of California but it's
not enough for Nevada officials like
Clark County Commissioner Jim Gibson or
Las Vegas mayor Carolyn Goodman a vocal
advocate for the completion tweeting on
Tuesday the need for it ahead of Las
Vegas's first Super Bowl I'm sure
California has all the expertise in the
world but there is a lot that needs to
be done to make that Highway safe
so Ryan took those concerns to Caltrans
they tell him the one mile third lane
expansion has saved drivers an average
of 30 to 40 minutes when driving to
California on those heavy days of
Sundays and Mondays but they could not
give a timeline for the further widening
and say lacking in funding though is not
a factor